what's going on there reject nation
we're gonna watch today a fun
spider-man video again this one is tom
hollands and dia and jacob babylon react
to their original cast auditions i've never
personally seen their cast auditions this
will be the first for a lot of people
involved anyhow if you could leave a
like flip that like button you know what
we say when it's spider-man let's get to it
wow i've wanted to see these for so long
so we're obviously shooting spider-man 3 and we're
all going to sit down and watch our audition tapes
that laughs
and walked back in the scene
have you ever played down earth
they are thrashing that limiter thank you
the self-care that's the best that's the best
i was just wondering if you're nervous about
the debate is this is supposed to follow
i think sex nicole has a pretty solid
legging yours is just really good
audition even back then oh yeah
right right he has mono tell me more
i feel like my whole audition i was like so
nervous that i can say the right words well
i'd say they made a good decision hey look not
me right now not us not us look at us look at us
good job guys wow good job everyone watching
that's great let's do it we should go and
make a movie exactly how we played those
scenes let's do it all right oh no goodness
i watched that movie i could barely watch a
video i did six months ago i can't imagine
what it's like to watch this thing when
you auditioned for it years ago especially
because you have that feeling of like i've
grown so much not only physically but also like
as a performer i think at that time i'd
imagine zendaya coming off of whatever
that disney thing that she was on probably had
the most fame and was most accustomed to like
the filmmaking and whatnot is probably more used
to seeing herself on camera because they even
joked about like yeah she's actually just doing
like a really good one this is like today actually
this is good acting yeah but you know especially
for people like tom hall and jacob battle on to
go back and realize like oh i've grown so much as
an actor for so much as talented to see that you
can see like where all that converting the cringe
into slamming on the table smacking things around
ah that was a that was a delight i really enjoyed
the hell out of that video yeah absolutely and
it's fun to see the things that maintained
from way back then that still made like that
laugh he does like some of those mannerisms
that made it into even the later movies are
still part of the performances even though they
are you know a little funny to look back on now
and yeah just to see yeah the way jacob battle
and walks out of frame comes back in to restart
the scene like things that yeah obviously now
you know you just go into it but it's so much
fun to see yeah like the very origins of that
and the sort of shy beginnings that led to the
biggest movie of all time or one of the biggest
movies of all time anyway can someone explain
to me in the comments i thought jacob battle
on is bald and he's wearing a wig i thought he
was even in his audition he was but then here in
this video when he's reacting he's wearing a wig
or is that his actual hair does he just prefer the
shaved look is it like when christian bale would
do american accents in his interviews when he was
playing an american character to not confuse the
audience i'm playing a guy with hair yeah did they
put on a wig just to not confuse people because 99
time when he does promos he's he's bald so i was
like whoa where'd all this had a hair come from
is that a wig or is that real i was a little bit
lost there but anyway yeah i mean looking back at
this footage and seeing just how much they've
all grown i would say that it's funny like tom
hall is obviously perhaps the biggest star of
the mall like uncharted was a big hit he is
spider-man however i think zendaya is like the
most talented one if you guys have watched i'm
telling you if you have not seen you before
yet hey you should definitely be of a certain
age if you haven't seen before you it's quite
mature content needless to say but there is
episodes in there where zendaya is just beyond
phenomenal and and such a nuanced natural actress
i can't stress that enough so i would like oh yeah
she's probably the better performer or charismatic
star and i don't really know jacob babylon's other
work i don't really know what else he's been in
do you nope just the spider might feel bad saying
that but just the spider-man movies although i
would love to see him in more things i mean i
feel like he does kind of get the bottom rung
of the totem pole because of the flashy stuff
that tom holland and zendaya are involved in but
he's really great and he's got great comedic
timing so i hope that yeah this still blossoms
outward for him as much as it does for them you
know i wonder if he still has to audition though
because every actor gets to a certain stage and
there's like other actors that i know of or i'm
still surprised by oh they make you audition still
like there's certain actors of certain levels that
i've met where you'd think they they only go off
of being offered roles because auditioning is just
this whole other process in and of itself into
like audition for a marvel film you got so much
competition you got a lot of people trying to get
that role so to narrow it down to the right person
there's just a lot of pressure on both ends
there's a lot of pressure on that one person
and who's going to play the role and there's
a lot of pressure on the people picking the
role and so many other variables go into that as
well i think the thing that i really like about
what marvel does is they seem to mainly
go off of the best performer for the job
more than anything else like i i'm fortunate
enough to know like enough you know producer
director people where i won't name drop anyone
but i know enough to the point where i can
get these stories of you you sit in all these
auditions and you hear like the craziest stuff
i've heard this before like that person's the best
actor but that other one has a bigger social media
following maybe we should go with her these are
like things they actually discuss in the casting
process in the audition room and it's so cool
to see that the three of them relatively unknown
or moderately known easily three not not like
super famous people to be able to get a chance
at this movie and to see just how popular they've
got it it's really is a story of overcoming odds
there's so many odds factored against you we're so
used to seeing people where they're already famous
we're already like hey overnight star something
like that but when you see this it just reminds
you of the hard work labor the focus commitment
all that factored in and on top of all that you
have to beat unsurmountable odds and they did it
so this is really inspiring to for them to go back
and see that it's like they might be laughing
and cringing but it's really inspiring really
yeah absolutely and too i mean i've heard a lot
of actors talk different ways about the self tape
versus being in the room and just looking at these
here it almost feels like yeah with that self tape
they're able to especially tom holland bring out
that creativity that i imagine bridges the gap
that much more into the charm that will lead to a
casting choice like that that whole thing with the
boots where he does the the web gag or he flips
into frame he won't be able to do that in the
room with the producers and stuff like that and so
yeah it also gets to show the creativity that can
sometimes be that extra ounce of lightning
in the bottle that gets you a roll like this
you know so it's it's it's a fascinating look at
the approach and and then you know i'm not like an
actor actor but you know thinking to me i'm like
damn it seems like almost self tape would be the
way to go because then you can be creative and put
your stamp on something without getting alienated
in the room because oftentimes in a person to
person environment that's actually discouraged
so yeah it's a good sort of glimpse into you know
what leads to these massive blockbusters as well
as any other indie movie true that all right guys
well uh spiderman no way home did you pre-order it
leave your thoughts down below thanks for
being here with us to have a good laugh
uh while funny also inspiring in a lot of
ways uh hey let's end this with the paper
oliver hey hamlet h-a-m-e-l-i-n guys
new patron you know the journal oh
standing for auto octavius hey
that works hey l standing for
level up because i think you are at the highest
level i for igniting my soul v for vendetta okay
e for equality because that's what oliver believes
in an r for a real one because you're the realest
of them all oliver oliver thank you so much for
being part of our patreon page you're a sexy sob
hopefully you enjoy the limited content
we put up over there very minor see ya